Great. So, let's now say a little bit
about what this course is. This is a
course on game theory or on the economic
applications of game theory. So, I think
a natural starting point is to ask what
is game theory?
Well, here's two definitions, both from
people who've won the Nobel Prize
for their work in game theory.
The first is by Roger Myerson who says
that game theory is the study of
mathematical models of conflict and
cooperation between intelligent rational
decision makers.
Robert Aumann gives also a Nobel
laureate gives just a briefer definition
which I think
encapsulates the key ideas. It's
interactive decision theory. It's about
people making decisions when the
decisions interact. What does it mean
for people's decisions interact? Well, I
think the best way to see it is just an
example. So, we're going to play a game
as a class to see what it means to be a
hopefully rational and intelligent
interactive decision maker. And then
after that, I'll get into the formal
material on the board. So, to play games
in the class, we're going to use a
platform called called MobLab. So, let
me just describe the game and then I'll
hit begin. You're each going to be
assigned a random number between 1 and
100. It's going to be an integer.
And then you're each going to make a
guess, which is also a number between 1
and 100. The winner of the game, I'm
sorry sorry, there's no real prizes but
pride. The winner of the game is the
person who guesses closest to 2/3 of the
average of everyone's number in the
class.
Okay? The number they guessed or the
number they were assigned?
The number they guessed.
Right. So, you're assigned a number,
only you know that. No one else knows
that number. You're going to make a
guess and the winning guess is the guess
that's closest to 2/3 of the average of
everyone in the class's guess. Yes. Is
every Is everyone's number drawn from a
uniform distribution? Yes.
Any other questions? Yes.
1 to 100. Yeah.
Any other questions? I think this
these details should be there but
sometimes they uh
they're a little imprecise in the way
they write it. Okay. Uh so, let's begin.
All right.
Here we are.
So, let's see. So, here
on the horizontal axis are the guesses
that people made. Again, to clarify, not
the numbers you got but the guesses that
people are making. And on the vertical
axis, we're showing the percentage of
people who made that particular guess.
So, we have a few to pick, maybe hard to
see with the color, but we have a few
summary statistics here. We see that the
average was
36, roughly. And that's the dotted
purple line
And the winning guess was the guess that
was closest to 2/3 of 36, so about 24.
And we see that guess is here.
Does anyone want to share their thought
process? Um maybe someone who was quite
high up here what they were thinking?
Or low. Anyone? Anyone who's willing to
to share what they're thinking about?
What about the winner? They should be
able to come forward. Who won?
Yes, you won. Okay, tell me uh what was
your reasoning?
Uh
Okay.
Yeah.
Great.
So, so great. So, you're showing the you
know, foundation of game theoretic
reasoning what we talked about
interactive decision making. You didn't
just think about your number, you had to
think about other people's numbers and
then you had to think about what other
people will do given the numbers that
they got. And you adjusted your strategy
accordingly. And in this case, uh it
worked out pretty well. Uh anyone else
who want to share maybe
a bid they're happy with, a bid they
feel they made a mistake on? Um any
other thoughts?
Yes.
26? Okay. So, you're pretty close, yeah?
Okay, that's fair. What about I mean
maybe they don't want to out themselves
but I'm kind of curious people guess
very high. Any
reasoning about that? No, maybe they
don't want to say anything. Okay, let's
play it one more time and see and see
what happens.
Ah.
So, quite different this time.
Uh so, now the average was 21.
And the winning choice was 14.
Uh that's interesting. So, uh this
happens every year. So, people are very
consistent. Uh so, the distribution has
changed a bit. So, anyone want to So,
some people must have decided to to bid
less this time. Anyone who bid less this
time, do they want to share
uh why?
It's quiet.
Anyone?
Okay. Do you want Can you say a little
more? So, so you thought something was a
good guess and now you're you're bidding
even less. And And why is that?
Right.
So, what we see is that interactive
decision making sometimes creates this
regress, right? So, first I have to
think about my number. That's certainly
relevant. Then I have to try to think
about what other people are going to do.
So, I have to think about what number
they have.
But now I have to put myself in the
shoes of those other people and say what
are they bidding? What are they going to
guess? Well, they're get they're
thinking about what I'm doing.
But when they try to think about what
I'm doing, they have to think about what
I think about what they're doing. So, I
have to think about what they think
about what I think what they think. And
all of a sudden, it gets very very hard,
right? And this is exactly what game
theory is trying to address. I think for
a while historically, if you go back to
the history of thought, people thought
you know, it's just an infinite regress.
There's no way we can try to analyze
games like this. And game theory is a
formal way to try to think about this
kind of reasoning process. Um this also
happens every year. Um a lot of people
shift to 100 after we talk about it. Um
why?
Uh you know, I think some people are
kind of mischievous. They want to They
want to try to shift the results and get
it wrong. So, I I think this highlights
a really important thing about game
theory that when we study game theory
and when we analyze a game,
a really important modeling choice is
writing down what people's preferences
actually are, what people want. So, if
you analyze this game assuming that
people's goal was to win,
your predictions might be wrong if some
people's goal is not actually to win.
So, I think some people's goal might be
to make my prediction look a little
silly or to make their friends laugh or
to kind of mess with things, right?
That's fine. That's their preference.
But we need to make sure we accurately
capture people's preferences when we
model games cuz if we don't, our
predictions are obviously going to be
wrong.
Another thing though that we have to
keep in mind is especially when
comparing the results we get in a lab or
in a classroom setting to the real world
is that the stakes really matter.
So, we have a lot of students maybe a
few students are kind of mischievous. If
you won $10
for guessing well, I think some of those
students wouldn't be so mischievous. And
if you won $100,000 for for winning, I
think very few students would be
mischievous. And I think once you get
high enough, essentially no students
would be mischievous, right? So, the
stakes and what you actually get for
winning are going to affect the
preferences that people have in this
game.
Okay, so let me let's move on. The plan
is to move on to the formal analysis
unless there are
any questions about this game. I should
say this is sometimes called the
Keynesian beauty contest. So, if you
want to Google it or read about it,
that's what it's often called. Yes.
Exactly right. So, with this many
people, the average of the numbers that
people got is is almost certain to be
very close to 50. Uh
but what this average is the average
choice. So, the average guess of people
in the class. And that's why the you
know, when we moved from the first round
to the second round, you know, I didn't
see all the realizations but it's likely
that the average number that people
received was basically the same in the
two rounds. But the average guess
changed dramatically because people
behaved differently in the second round
after we had this discussion. And we
could keep doing this, you know, we have
limited class time but my guess if we
played this 10 times, we might see
people getting very very close to zero
and my guess is then some people at 100
to to mess with things. Uh
any other question Was there a question
here?
Yeah, or comment, yeah.
Oh, maybe I'm
Oh, yeah, you're right. Sorry, there's
no number, yeah. I'm
Yeah, yeah, good point. Uh I'm I'm I'm
getting ahead to the next game we play.
You're right. Sorry, you weren't
assigned a number, yeah. Um
uh sorry, that was very confusing. Uh we
play another game where you get a number
and uh fair enough. There's no Yeah, you
don't get a number. There's no
uniformity.
Yeah, fair enough. Okay, I'm uh getting
ahead of myself.
Thanks for the clarification.
Um
Okay, let us
get to the board.
There we go. So, on the problem set,
you'll analyze a variant of this game
where you will get a number. So, that'll
be coming.
Let's open this up.
Okay. So, let's get started.
So, first let me say a little bit more
about what we said was the definition of
game theory.
Which we said was the study of
interacting
rational decision makers.
>> So, let's break down each of the terms
in this definition. Let's go backwards
from kind of easiest to hardest.
Uh so, I think the the basic thing is
that we're studying decision makers.
We're studying people who make
decisions, and that means people are
making choices. So, another good word
for decision that we'll use a lot in the
course is people are making either
choices or we might also call it
actions.
And game theory is a very abstract
general mathematical theory
that applies to a huge range of choices
and actions. So, in the game you just
played, where you chose a number to
guess, that was an example of a choice.
Whether you go to MIT is another example
of a choice or action that we could
analyze in game theory. What price a
firm sets um is another example of a
choice. Uh which country you move to,
what job you choose,
um how many hours a week you work, these
are all these different questions. Um
what platform a political party chooses
coming up to an election, who someone
votes for, these are all actions or
choices that people make.
And the generality and abstractness of
game theory is what allows it to be
applied to so many different settings.
And throughout the course, we're going
to talk about various applications of
game theory, mainly within economics,
but also to some things beyond
economics, like to political science and
um you know, political bargaining.
What does rational mean?
So, this is certainly a sticking point
of game theory. If you've mentioned game
theory to someone, whenever I'm on a
plane and people ask me what I do, and I
say I'm a game theorist, I always get
the same response, but aren't people not
rational, right? Uh you probably don't
get asked about game theory on planes as
much as I do, but uh maybe maybe someday
you will. Um
And you know, I want to be cautious
about how we interpret rationality. In
some contexts, this is a very bad
assumption.
There's no question about that.
Um but in other contexts, I think it's a
better assumption than people might
think.
And the reason for that is that the way
we use the term rationality within game
theory is a bit different than the way
we use it colloquially in everyday
language.
So,
what you might often hear someone on the
street say is it's so irrational
for this person to like this political
candidate.
In our model of rational choice, we
wouldn't ever say someone's preferences
are irrational.
If that's what they like, that's what
they like. So, rationality, I think a
better way to think of it is it's really
about consistency.
The agents in the models that we study
are going to act
towards achieving some consistent
objective. You might disagree with the
objective they have. They might like a
different flavor of ice cream or a
different political candidate, or put
different weight on income and leisure.
That's fine.
We don't all have to have the same
preferences, but the assumption is that
people consistently
uh act with an eye towards these
preferences that they do have.
So, uh sometimes
this is phrase that we say, and I like
to say is that preferences cannot be
irrational.
What can be irrational in the context of
game theory, choices giving preferences.
So, liking chocolate ice cream is not
irrational, even if you really like
vanilla, if your friend likes chocolate,
that's fine. But if your friend likes
chocolate and they choose vanilla, we
would call that choice irrational
because they're not maximizing their
objective.
Now, consistency,
how, you know, now I've sort of shifted
the the goalpost instead of trying to
defend rationality as a game theory
assumption, I'm now trying to mention
consistency. Again, sometimes it
applies, sometimes it doesn't. My guess
is your preferences today as
20-year-olds are very different from the
preferences you had 18 years ago.
So, if we're looking at a model of
people's choices over life, this
probably isn't a very good uh
description, or at least we might need
to enrich the model to capture that. But
if we're looking at your your choices or
preferences today and tomorrow, it
probably is a pretty a pretty good uh
assumption.
And then, interacting.
This is the key thing that distinguishes
game theory from a lot of other um
decision problems that we study in
economics, and it's exactly what we saw
in this first game. It's that um
multiple people are making decisions,
but it's more than that. There are a lot
of situations where we all make
decisions, but there's no interaction
between the decisions. So, we don't
really have to take into account what
decisions other people make. What
distinguishes game theory, and what I
mean by interacting decisions, is that
when I'm choosing what decision to make
myself, I have to take into account what
other people are going to do.
Because what other people do affects my
preferences. So, this is often called
this situation is often called STRATEGIC
INTERDEPENDENCE.
WHAT'S BEST FOR ME
depends upon what other people do.
So, a classic example where this is used
would be penalty kicks or tennis serves,
right?
Should the shooter shoot left or right?
Well, there's no inherent reason to
shoot left or right, but whether they
should shoot left or right depends upon
which way the goalie is going to dive,
or which way the tennis serve receiver
is planning to play. The best action for
one player depends upon what other
people are doing, and that's going to be
what we study today.
So, that's this course.
What about this class today?
We're actually going to
drop interacting and just study a single
rational decision maker. That's going to
be our baseline for today, because
before we can study how rational
decision makers interact, we have to
study how rational decision makers act
in isolation.
So, today, and then the rest of the
course will be about interaction.
Today, we're going to study what's
called individual decision making.
Of course, up here,
we still have individuals, but the key
is that they're interacting with other
individuals. So, maybe individual is not
the best term, but this is what's used.
We're going to study interact individual
decision making.
WANT TO MAKE ONE FINAL COMMENT ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF GAME THEORY,
which is the question of who's taking
these actions.
Um we often think of it as an individual
making choices, but it can be applied
much more broadly. So, there's a lot of
applications of game theory to
evolution, where we think of animals or
species kind of collectively taking
actions. We might also think about firms
or organizations, governments taking
actions, committees taking actions. And
I think now, with, you know, the rise
of, you know, artificial [snorts]
intelligence, there's a lot of interest
in thinking of the agents in our models
as being an LLM or some algorithm that's
taking an action and interacting with
people. So, one view that is kind of
becoming common,
we can debate about it, is that the
rationality assumptions of game theory
become more useful and more compelling
in a world of artificial intelligence.
We can debate about that, but that's a
view that some people express.
Okay. So, here we are, individual
decision making.
Let's start with a very simple problem.
A simple what I might call decision or
choice problem.
Nothing deep here, nothing that
interesting about the problem, but I
just want to show how we can set it up.
So, let's say that you're choosing
between three things.
Let's say you're at a cafe, and it's
coffee, espresso, and tea. So, we have
uh
three choices.
Coffee, which I'll label C,
espresso, which I'll label E,
and tea, which I'll label T.
And let's not think about prices. Of
course, maybe coffee's cheaper, but for
now, let's not think about prices. You
just get a choice, your friend's paying,
you're choosing between these these
three things.
The first component that we need to
think about in this decision problem is
what are these preferences. Remember, we
said that we're studying decision makers
who consistently maximize some sort of
preference. So, we need to specify this
agent's preferences.
And in this case, their preferences are
going to specify some ordering amongst
these three choices. So, a great way to
represent this in this context would be
C
better than E
better than T. So, these are probably my
preferences.
What does this mean? It means I prefer
drinking coffee to drinking espresso.
I prefer drinking espresso to drinking
tea.
And the way I've written this suggests
transitivity, which you will assume that
if I prefer coffee to espresso and
espresso to tea, then I must also prefer
coffee to tea. I won't write that out
explicitly, but that's implied by this.
And there's an there's an implicit
transitivity assumption that we're
making.
But I think this actually raises kind of
a difficult philosophical question. What
does it mean to prefer coffee to
espresso? What is a preference?
You know, philosophers talk about this.
Maybe people who study cognitive
sciences go to the lab and they try to
measure people's brain activity and say,
"Oh, when you drink coffee, a different
neuron activates." Uh you know,
philosophers will get into these long
debates about what it means to have a
preference. In economics, we take a much
more operational
view of preferences. What does it mean,
and it's almost tautological, what does
it mean that I prefer coffee to
espresso? It means when I'm faced with a
choice between coffee and espresso, I
choose coffee. That's all it means. So,
this is the decision-based view of
preferences that's predominant in
economics. So, let's say, what is the
meaning of this?
The meaning is that I if I'm given a
choice between coffee and espresso, I
choose coffee.
I'm not going to be too precise here. We
might argue about strict preferences
versus weak preferences, and maybe we
can have be indifferent between things,
but for now, let's just think about
strict preferences.
And preferences are pairwise object,
right? So, a preference says, "For any
two things, which do I prefer between
them?" So, one way of thinking about
what we mean by preferences is we're
describing what an agent would choose
from any pair or any menu containing two
items.
And then, from that primitive
preference, we can talk about what they
would choose in richer problems.
Now,
an issue is that these little, you know,
squiggly inequality signs are kind of
messy to deal with. So, it often becomes
more convenient in economics to use a
utility representation of preferences.
So, let me go to a new board for this.
This didn't go all the way up. Let's
see.
There we go.
And
I'll define the word ordinal in a
second, but I'm going to talk about an
ordinal
utility
representation of preferences.
Why do we use this? Well, it's just more
convenient. Especially when we have a
lot of things, specifying all my
pairwise preferences between these
things can get kind of cumbersome.
So, what we do is we just specify a
function called utility function. So,
let's give just an example here. So,
maybe my utility function is
U of C equals 5,
U of E
equals 4,
and U of T equals 1.
This should be one utility
representation of these preferences. Why
do these utilities represent these
preferences? Well, do I prefer C to E?
Yes, because the utility assigned to C
is higher than the utility assigned to
E.
Do I prefer E to T? Well, yes, because
the utility assigned to E
is strictly greater than the utility
assigned to T.
And if we have a utility function like
this, you can check that our induced
preferences
are going to satisfy transitivity as
well. Because if one number is bigger
than another, and that other number is
bigger than a third number, then the
first number is bigger than the third
number.
But, we have an issue here that this is
only a representation.
So, I could also write down an
alternative utility function. Maybe I'll
call this U1.
Let me now write down a utility function
U2
that's this.
Ah,
two.
What about these preferences? Are these
the same preferences or these different
preferences than the first utility
function?
What do people think?
I don't think there's really one right
answer, but
The same, right? So, it is true that if
this were my utility representation, it
still says I prefer C to E,
I prefer E to T,
and I prefer C to T. So, this is an
alternative representation of the same
preferences.
And this is what we mean by an ordinal
utility representation. Only the order
matters.
Let me say this.
AND BECAUSE ONLY THE ORDER MATTERS, THAT
HAS A FEW IMPLICATIONS.
The first is that there's many
representations, many utility
representations of the same preferences.
Many ordinal representations.
And the second, I think more subtle
point is that the units and the values
in the utility function don't have
meaning.
In fact, what are the units of utility
functions? They don't really have a unit
that makes sense. Sometimes we call the
units utils.
Um
but
from a purely preference standpoint, you
might look at this, you might say, "Oh,
I like C more in this world than in this
world." But, no. The way we think about
ordinal representations is that what
matters are your preferences,
and there's a convenient mathematical
way to represent them like this, and
this is another convenient mathematical
way to represent them, and they
represent the same preferences, and
there's no meaning associated with these
utility functions in this ordinal world.
Yes. Would you have to like specify like
a null option then? Like
let's say like if the utility is -100
for T,
would you have to specify that like they
can also choose nothing? Great, that's a
good point. So, when we write when we
write a choice problem, it's really
crucial and it's sort of implicit in
what I did, but I didn't say it
explicitly, so thanks for bringing this
up, that
I can make only one choice,
and every possible choice is included,
right? So, if you have four options, if
only three of them are included, that's
not going to capture your your
preference problem, your your choice
problem. So, really, if I were being
careful, probably this is actually a
more complicated problem, and there's a
third option, which is not drinking any
drink.
And I should really specify the utility
here. So, in this simple thing, I'm
imagining for some reason you have to
make one of these three choices, but
you're right, in general, when we model
a choice problem, it's important to
capture every possible choice the agent
could make.
On the other on the other side, indeed,
if it's possible for me to choose both
coffee and espresso, then that needs to
be formally modeled as another choice,
the bundle where I get coffee and
espresso, because that's a separate
choice that I can make.
Good point.
Okay, so this is ordinal utility
representations, and now I'm going to
move to the opposite, cardinal
representations, and everything I said
here
is going to go the other way. So, let's
be really clear, everything I just said
is going to be wrong in a different
context. So, let's be be very careful.
So, this is ordinal.
The issue
is that often in game theory, we face
decisions under uncertainty.
And when we face decisions under
uncertainty, we need to model
preferences a bit differently.
So, let's now move to decisions under
uncertainty.
What is a decision under uncertainty
mean? It means when I make a choice, I
don't know exactly what the consequence
of that choice will be.
When I buy an index fund or buy a stock,
I don't know whether that stock is going
to go up or down.
I can't choose. Of course, if I could
choose the stock that made more money, I
would choose that one. But, that's not
my choice. I'm choosing one stock that
has some distribution over outcomes that
I don't know what the outcomes will be,
and then I might choose another stock,
and again, I don't know exactly what the
outcome of that stock will be. And
that's what we mean by uncertainty.
So, let's look at again a very, very
simple problem,
not economically interesting, but just
to convey the ideas,
which is the choice of how to get home.
Let's say you're choosing whether to
walk home or to take the subway.
So, you can either walk home
or take the subway.
Maybe we'll call that S, and we'll call
this W. And again, here we're assuming
you have to get home. Maybe there's a
third option where you stay at work all
day, but we're not going to model that.
And now, why is this a decision under
uncertainty? Well, you don't know what
the weather's going to be like. You have
a long walk home, so the weather could
change as you walk home.
And we're going to assume this two-ways
world could be. Again, weather is more
complicated, but this is a
simplification of reality. It could be
sunny or it could be rainy.
Maybe we should really model every
possible temperature and every possible
level of precipitation, but we're not
going to do that.
And the way things work is when it's
sunny, you'd rather walk home,
and when it's rainy, you'd rather take
the subway.
Okay? So, maybe I'll say I'll write this
over here. If sunny,
you prefer
and I think sometimes I call this the T
to avoid the S.
Let's call this the T.
And V T A.
Just so we don't see the the two S's.
If sunny, you prefer to walk home, and
if rainy,
prefer to take the T.
So, how would you approach this problem?
I mean, this is a very simple problem
people take uh
a simple choice people make all the
time. Um how would you approach this?
What do you do when you Do you just
randomly go home?
Uh
or do you think a little bit?
What's relevant? What do you need to
know to approach this problem?
Yeah. You check the weather app. You
check the weather app, right? And what
does that tell you?
If it's sunny or rainy. Okay. And right,
it might tell you and really it might
give you some Or do you want to go
ahead? Yeah. I feel like how likely it
is. Yeah, it's going to tell you it
might say sun or rain, but also it might
give you a likelihood of sun or rain,
right? And oftentimes you're not certain
if it's going to be sunny or rainy, you
have some uncertainty. That's
the the key thing that we're having
here. So, this problem, if you knew the
weather, would be very easy. If you knew
for certain it was going to be sunny, we
know you'd walk home, and if you knew
for certain it was going to rain, you'd
take the T. The issue is that you have
uncertainty, and indeed, when you check
the weather app, what you do is you form
beliefs. And this is going to be kind of
a foundational idea uh in in this
course, that in the face of uncertainty,
what do you do? You form beliefs.
So, this is In game theory, we take a
fundamentally Bayesian view of the
world. When we have uncertainty, we say,
"Well,
we don't know whether it's going to be
sunny or rainy, but we might say
something like there's a 20% chance that
it's sunny."
So, we'll assign beliefs, and in this
case, let's represent our belief by the
probability P that it's sunny,
and then correspondingly, we have the
probability
1 minus P that it's rainy.
So, these are my beliefs.
Okay. And now, I'm going to fill in some
utilities here. Uh
I'm going to say
7 2
5 5.
So, this is a representation of my
preferences, and indeed, when it's
sunny, I prefer walking to taking the T,
and when it's rainy, I prefer taking the
T to walking.
Okay. So, now we've written things down.
Now I'd ask again, now we've specified
our beliefs, which would you choose? How
would you approach this choice?
So in this course we're going to assume
expected utility, but I want to point
out that that's not so obvious, right?
One thing you might say, you might say
look, I'm an optimistic person.
If I walk, the best thing that can
happen is I get seven.
If I take the T, the best thing that can
happen is I get five. Seven is higher
than five, I'm going to walk. I'm an
optimistic person.
You might say I'm a pessimistic person.
I'm really afraid uh the worst case
outcome.
So when I walk, I could get two.
When I take the T, I'm the worst I can
get is five, that's better, so I'm going
to take the T.
I think the view in game theory is that
optimism and pessimism are better
reflected in your beliefs, and uh we're
generally going to assume in this course
expected utility.
But I want to point out that this is an
assumption.
There's an axiomatic foundation, so
decision theorists think a lot about the
question, why should we use expected
utility?
Or more concretely, if we assume that
agents use expected utility, what
assumption are we making? What does that
mean about their behavior when we assume
expected utility? How restrictive is
that assumption? And there's uh an
appendix in the lecture notes that's
posted online where you can look at this
axiomatic approach to expected utility
theory, but in this course we're just
going to take it as given that people
always use expected utility. So what
does that mean? It's two steps.
First they form beliefs.
Now how reasonable is it to think that
people form beliefs about the thing
they're uncertain about? Well, I think
it depends on the context.
In this problem I think it's very
reasonable. You open your weather app,
it gives you some probability of rain or
or sun, you might think, oh I don't
really trust the weather app, it always
overestimates or underestimates, you
might adjust, but you'll form your
belief.
But if I say, you know, form your belief
about the prob- about, you know, what is
the probability that in 15 years your
income will be between be between these
two numbers?
That's pretty hard to form beliefs
about. So I think this assumption that
you start by forming beliefs about what
you don't know is a very realistic
assumption in very simple problems, but
as we get to very very rich problems and
complicated problems, you might worry
that this is
uh not a very well-founded assumption
when we get to complicated choices.
Maybe your choice, you know, about what
job to take today depends on your belief
about how likely it is that you have a
grandchild in 40 years who's short on
money and needs the the money that you
saved based on your job today. What's
the probability or let's go deeper.
What's the probability that in 10
generations your, you know, 10th degree
grandchild is going to be short on
money. Well, that's really hard to form
beliefs about, right? So in that context
maybe this is an unrealistic assumption,
but it's going to be the assumption we
make in this class and we're going to
apply this to models where we think it's
a reasonable assumption.
And then the next thing that you do,
given that you formed your beliefs, is
you compute your expected utility from
each choice.
But now we have a bit of an issue.
Because I said up here when I talked
about ordinal utility representations
that the numbers didn't matter.
But now all of a sudden the numbers will
matter. Because when I compute the
expectation, my expected utility from
walking,
if seven were 700, that's going to
change my expected utility.
So we have to really crucially
understand that in this model these
utilities are different. These are no
longer ordinal utilities. So
in the decision-making under
uncertainty,
so in this context,
utility is cardinal.
As opposed to ordinal.
Ordinal means only the order matters,
that's where the word ordinal comes
from. Cardinal means the size or the
actual numbers matter.
And the way we distinguish this
is we say that this utility function
here is a von Neumann-Morgenstern
utility function.
And basically throughout this course,
we're going to focus on this case of
uncertainty and essentially all the
utility functions we work with are going
to be
cardinal utility functions or von
Neumann utility functions rather than
ordinal utility functions. And just to
kind of understand the landscape, up
here we didn't make any expected utility
assumptions. This was a very abstract
approach to any preference problem.
When we're in the world of uncertainty
and we restrict attention to expected
utility preferences, in that more
restricted environment we're always
going to work with what are called von
Neumann-Morgenstern utility functions
where the numerical value actually
matters.
So let's see how we would approach this
problem in this VNM context.
So we have two choices. We have walking
and taking the T.
And what I'm generally going to use is
this von Neumann-Morgenstern utility
function U. This is a small U.
But then when I compute expected
utilities, your expected utility is
going to be a big U. So I'm going to now
compute here
U of walking
and U of taking the T, and this is a big
U.
And of course with handwriting it's not
obvious what it is, so if you're ever
unsure, you can ask me. But let's make
sure we understand that these functions
are defined for different objects.
My cardinal utility
tells me what is my utility from walking
when it's sunny.
What is my utility from walking when
it's rainy? And it gives me these four
numbers.
My
big U, my expected utility, isn't
assigned to a weather-choice pair, it's
assigned just to the choice.
So for my big U I can say what is my
expected utility from walking.
My little U tells me my utility from
walking in each state of the world.
So let's just compute this. It's going
to be, you know, quite easy. The math
here is not the point, it's about
conceptually.
So if I walk, well with probability P I
get seven and with probability 1 minus P
I get two, so my expected utility is
P times seven
plus 1 minus P times two.
And if I take the T,
well, it's P times five
plus 1 minus P
times five.
Well, this is easy, right? The
expectation of of this is just going to
be five, right? It's five either way. So
this is
five.
And then here what do I get? I get
I get two minus two P, so plus
five P.
So which do I prefer?
Well, it depends on P, right? If P is
really really small, if P gets close to
zero, then this becomes two and I prefer
five to two, so I prefer taking the T.
That makes sense. If I look outside and
it looks really really rainy, I'm going
to take the T.
If P is really really high, well let's
say P is one, I know it's going to be
sunny,
then if I walk I get seven. If I sorry,
if I yes, if I walk I get seven, if I
take the T I get five. Seven is more
than five, so therefore uh I prefer to
walk.
When will I walk rather than take the T?
Well, I have to compare these two
numbers. So when is two plus five P
greater than equal to five? Let's ask
that question.
Well, it's if five P is greater than
equal to three.
So it's if P
is greater than equal to three fifths,
right?
I'm sure someone will check
the math.
So yeah.
Ah, good good point. So when P is
exactly three fifths, I'm indifferent
between the two. So I need some word for
that. So I guess I would say I weakly
prefer
walking to taking the T
if P is greater than equal to three
fifths, and I strictly prefer walking to
taking the T if P is strictly greater
than three fifths.
Uh
Sorry, say again?
Exactly, yeah.
I see.
You're right, so there's a bit of
ambiguity there. So maybe I'll put if if
this makes it let's let's say this,
yeah. In I would say, let's focus on the
case where P is not three fifths, then
it's pretty clear. When P is exactly
three fifths, you're right, we wouldn't
have an inherent preference for walking
over taking the T. We in that case we
would be indifferent between walking and
taking the T. So maybe I'll I'll make a
note up here and sometimes you use a
squiggle for that. So we might say
W squiggle T, I'm indifferent between
walking and taking the T exactly if
P
equals three fifths.
Yeah.
And in this case it's a strict
preference. So here what this says,
which I think is sort of an intuitive
model of decision-making, that I'm going
to choose to walk home when I check my
weather app and I think it's
sufficiently likely that it's sunny.
How sufficiently likely? Well, in this
case it's exactly 60% chance of sun that
makes it worth it for me to walk home.
Now where did we get this number from?
It depended on the numerical values over
here.
If these numerical values were
different, if I made this 700, well,
then I'm basically always going to walk
home unless I'm absolutely certain
basically it's going to rain. So, that
again shows us that the cardinal values
of these utility functions are going to
affect the decisions that we make.
Any other question on this? Yeah.
No, I would say I
I would say the right way to think about
preferences, I was being a little, you
know, loose over there to make it
quicker, but I'd say really there's
three
possibilities when you compare two
things. You can strictly prefer one to
the other.
You can strictly prefer the other to the
first one, or you can be indifferent.
There's really three possibilities, and
when I compare my expected utilities,
there's again three possibilities.
Either one is strictly higher, the
other's strictly higher, or we're
exactly indifferent. And in general,
when people are indifferent, um it's
harder to make predictions about what
they'll do. They might randomize, they
might choose one, they might choose the
other. We're not going to really take a
strong stance on what people do in that
case. Thanks for clarifying. Yeah. Any
other questions?
All right. So, now let's be a bit more
formal. This was uh a very simple
example, but let's formalize this a bit.
I guess I have one more board.
So, maybe I'll say VNM.
This is von Neumann-Morgenstern that I
said before, and I'll call this the VNM
setting.
So, generally this is the approach we're
going to take in this course. We're
going to start with a really simple
example to motivate the theory. We're
then going to present a more general
abstract model, and then we're going to
go back to more concrete and more
interesting applications that are more
substance. So, that's kind of the three
steps we'll take. So, what's the setting
here? Well, there's going to be a set Z,
which we'll say is the
and I'll
call this Z1
through ZM.
And this is the set of
maybe outcomes
or consequences.
And we have to be really careful about
how we define outcomes and consequences.
So, in this game that we described,
there are actually four outcomes.
I walk home in the sun, I walk home in
the rain, I take the T in the sun, and I
take the T in the rain.
It's important to understand the outcome
has to capture everything about my
choice. It's not directly my choice. I'm
not directly choosing outcomes. I'm
choosing effectively lotteries over
outcomes, and the outcome has to capture
everything that's relevant uh in the
situation.
So, we have this set Z of outcomes or
consequences, and then we have the von
Neumann-Morgenstern utility function
little U.
Now, just as we saw over here, little U
assigned a number to each of our four
outcomes.
So, U is going to be a function
from Z
to R.
So, I'm going to use this function
notation a lot in the course. When I put
a letter and then a colon, that means
this is a function that assigns to every
item in this set, every object in this
set, something in this set. So, in this
case it assigns to every outcome Z, and
so I'll write it like this underneath,
what we'll call U of Z.
And U of Z is the cardinal von
Neumann-Morgenstern utility I get from
the outcome Z.
Now,
given the set of outcomes and my von
Neumann-Morgenstern utility, we can
consider my expected utility.
Let me write it this.
So, my expected utility is the big U.
And what is this going to be defined
over? It's really crucial that this is
defined over a different set. So, what
do I assign expected utilities to?
Yeah? Would it be the set of actions?
Uh so, it it would in this context it
was a set of actions, but in this
abstract model, good question. Oh, yeah?
Like the state of the world.
Okay. Uh so, I would say a maybe a bit
of an a vague question. I would say the
set of lotteries over
outcomes. So, let's be clear. Here,
you're right, we were choosing actions.
We chose whether to walk or take the
MBTA. But the way we think about those
actions in this abstract setting is that
each one corresponds to a lottery.
Walking is the lottery where with
probability P, I walk in the sun,
and with probability 1 - P, I walk in
the rain.
And similarly, the MBTA is a different
lottery where with probability P, I get
this outcome, and with probability 1 -
P, I get this outcome. So, we need some
notation for lotteries. I'm going to use
throughout the course
delta of Z.
I don't want the notation to scare
people, it's just going to make it
easier for us to talk about things. So,
Z is our set of outcomes. Delta of Z is
the set of lotteries over these
outcomes.
So, in this context,
where we only had two outcomes, a
lottery just specified two numbers, P
and 1 - P, right? And because those
numbers sum to one, it was really only
one number that mattered. Once we knew
P, we were able to calculate 1 - P. But
in general, we're looking at a situation
where there are M outcomes instead of
just two.
So, what is a lottery?
So, contains
I'll call lotteries.
And again, I should be clear, the use of
lottery colloquially is different from
in econ. You know, we're not literally
talking about buying lottery tickets,
we're using this more abstractly, is a
vector P
that specifies the probability of each
of these outcomes.
So, P1
through PM.
The lottery says with probability P1,
you get consequence Z1, with probability
PM, you get consequence ZM. These are
probabilities, so what what has to be
true about them? They have to be
non-negative. You can't have negative
probabilities, and they have to sum to
one.
So,
we'll say P1
up to PM are greater than or equal to
zero,
and P1 [applause]
plus PM
equals one.
So, delta of Z is the set of all of
these probability vectors or lotteries
that satisfy these properties.
And now our expected utility function U
is a function
from delta Z to R.
It says for any lottery, what is my
expected utility from that lottery? So,
again using the notation above, we would
call a lottery P,
and that would go
to U of P.
So, this distinction is crucial, right?
A VNM utility says for each outcome,
what is my utility from that outcome?
And expected utility big U says for each
lottery over outcomes, what is my
expected utility from that lottery?
Um yes, question?
Just to clarify, when we say lottery,
that's what we're modeling your decision
as is opting into a specific lottery.
Right. So, in the face of uncertainty,
um we're going to imagine that each
choice that you make is going to induce
some lottery over outcomes, and we're
going to represent the choice by that
lottery. This is an important point
because it could be that
Yeah. There's an embedded assumption
there, but I'll just say, yeah, that's
what we're assuming. Yes. Can you just
say what like U would be in this case?
Yes. So, I'm going to let me write the
definition, and then I'll give you an
example exactly. So,
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Um so, let's first
give the general definition, and then
I'll go to this example. So, U of P
equals what? Well, I'm just going to sum
over all the possible outcomes. There
are M outcomes, so I'm going to take and
let me not use summation notation cuz I
think that makes it just seem harder
than it is. So, let me write P1
U of Z1
So, I'm saying with probability P1, I
get outcome Z1, and this is my utility,
and I sum it all the way up until I get
to PN. This is the probability of
outcome N, and I get utility this. So,
in the if you wanted to really formally
write this in the example over here,
uh so, in the example,
walking
corresponded to a particular lottery,
right? Now, if I really want to write
out the example, I need to write out all
four of these things. So, maybe I'll
call these
uh
Z1,
Z2,
Z3,
Z4. Okay? These are the four
consequences of my actions.
Now, what is walking here? We need to
specify four numbers, right? P1, P2,
P3, P4.
What are these four numbers in this
example?
Well,
if I walk, I either get this box with
probability P,
or this box with probability 1 - P.
So, of these four numbers, two of them
are zero. Z P3 and P4
are both zero.
Why? Because it's impossible for me to
get one of those consequences. If I
choose to walk home, there's no way, oh,
I got a lucky, I'm now on the T. We're
not we're not imagining that can happen.
What can happen is you can either walk
home and it gets wet, or you walk home
and you don't. So, we have Z1 is going
to be P,
1 - P here.
And
if we compute it, what is U of this
particular P going to be?
Well, we go through, and we get P
U of Z1
plus 1 - P U of Z2
plus zero plus zero. I'm not going to
include the last two terms cuz they
disappear.
And this is going to be exactly what we
said before, P * 7
plus 1 - P
* 2.
Which we already computed. Any questions
on that?
Yes.
Yeah, so what I would say is
in principle, you can evaluate and this
is the key distinction between
preferences and choices. In principle,
you could say, "If I were offered a
lottery between these outcomes, you
know, this lottery versus this lottery,
what would I prefer?" Those are your
preferences. But in reality, you're
given a limited menu of lotteries that
you can actually choose from and you're
going to make a choice between those
lotteries. So, I could say in my head,
"What would I prefer between a stock
that always pays return of 1,000% and a
stock that always pays return of
-1,000%?" I know which one I'd prefer
and I can compute my preferences, but
there may not actually be a company
listed on the stock market that is going
to give me that lottery. In reality, I'm
going to face a limited choice set, a
limited menu of options. Each of those
options will induce a lottery and I'll
make a choice among this smaller
collection of lotteries. In this case,
that collection had two lotteries, the
walking lottery and the taking the T
lottery.
Uh
I would say it's a function, so it's
defined for every single lottery. I can
say for every single lottery what my
expected utility is, even for lotteries
that I may not have the option to choose
in a given situation. Yeah. Yes.
Good question. So, this is going to be a
big difference between individual
decision making and interactive decision
making. In individual decision making,
all of this uncertainty is just going to
be exogenous and that's the model I've
written down. But we'll see when we get
to interactive decision making, well,
how do I form beliefs about the choices
that other people make? And then we're
going to have to impose more structure
on these beliefs. But for the individual
context, we think of them as exogenous
through introspection, you form your
beliefs about what nature does, not what
other players do.
Okay, so one final thing is in the last
5 minutes,
um there's a special case which is of a
lot of importance
and I'll say sort of the key special
case
is going to be what we call money
lotteries.
So, these are more like the lotteries
that you hear about, you know, in
reality.
And why do I call it a special case?
Well, it's the special case where Z, the
set of outcomes, is just a set of
monetary rewards. So, I'll say Z is
equal to R and this means the real
number line.
Now, before I said Z was finite, here
I'm going to be a little loose and allow
Z to be infinite, right? So, the outcome
here is I get $1, I get $10, I get a
billion dollars. These are all outcomes.
So, what is a lottery? Let's consider
two lotteries.
One lottery maybe pays
uh $10.
So, let's now consider two lotteries.
Now, here with infinitely many things,
it could be more complicated, but I'm
going to look at lotteries where there's
a small number of things that could
actually happen. So, under this lottery,
there's only two outcomes that could
happen. Every other outcome has
probability zero. Under this lottery,
with probability 0.99, I get $10.
And with probability 0.01, I get
nothing. I get zero.
With this lottery, I get $1,000 with
probability 0.01
and I get zero with probability 0.99.
So, the two different lotteries, they
fit within our framework and we can
compute our expected utility of these
lotteries. How? Well, to do that, we
need our VNM utility function,
which is a function, remember, from Z to
R,
but in this case, Z is just R.
Let's understand this is money
and this is utility.
So, which of these lotteries would you
prefer? There's no right answer. Again,
preferences can be uh not irrational,
but what's your preference
between these?
It is, yeah?
You like the first one? Okay, I think
most people would and and why is that?
Um
because
I don't know. It seems like about like
1,000 divided by whatever seems to be
about
and then it seems
Right, so that's a great way of thinking
about it. So, the first thing you might
say is let's compare the expected values
of these lotteries.
The expected value of this is exactly
$10, right? 1/100 of 1,000 has expected
value $10.
What's the expected value of this? It's
$9.90.
So, this has a lower monetary expected
value.
But despite it having a lower monetary
expected value, it might have a higher
expected utility
and many people would choose this
lottery over this lottery exactly
because of what you said, it's safer.
So, what's key is
through our von Neumann-Morgenstern
utility function U,
when we evaluate lotteries, we don't
just compare the expected monetary
amount of the lotteries, we compare the
expected utility between the lotteries.
Um and what you're describing is what a
lot of people feature in this context
is, I'll say often,
U is
a concave function.
So, if I were to draw U,
for a lot of people,
their U is something like this.
And when U is concave, it means people
are what we call
risk-averse.
So, in this case, you exhibited risk
aversion.
You
preferred this lottery to this lottery
even though it had a smaller expected
value.
And
if we want to formally define what does
risk aversion mean,
a risk-averse person
is someone who always prefers a
certainty
at the expected value of a lottery to
the lottery itself. So, let me just
write this mathematically and explain
it.
Someone is risk-averse
if
deciding between a lottery P, let's take
this as an example, this is one lottery
P,
and another lottery that pays the
expected value of P with certainty.
In this case, that would be exactly $10.
Someone who's risk-averse would always
prefer getting $10 for sure
to getting a lottery whose expected
monetary amount was $10. And
mathematically, that's captured by the
concavity of the utility function here,
U.
For this to be a strict preference, we
need P to be non-degenerate, right? One
P would be you get something with
probability one. So, I as long as it's
non-degenerate, this is the meaning of
risk aversion. And this kind of answers
a puzzle, I mean, going back to the
1700s where people said, "Why would you
choose this lottery over this one? This
one has a higher expected value." And
the answer is, well, your utility
function is not the same as money. You
don't maximize expected money, you
maximize expected utility and some
people's utilities can be concave like
this.
So, let me stop there and I will see
everyone next week.